ein präsident unter druck über 100.000
corona tote und der streit mit twitter
setzen
donald trump zu gefahr für die
demokratie
trotz internationalen protest für
schließt peking neue gesetze für
hongkong und ein komplexer find das
corona virus greift nicht nur die lunge
sondern auch andere organe an
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg der nachrichtenüberblick
an diesem donnerstag guten abend und
willkommen
mehr als 100.000 tote fast 41 millionen
arbeitslose corona erschüttert die usa
aber den präsidenten scheint derzeit vor
allem eines zu beschäftigen seien streit
mit twitter auslöser ist dieser tweet
donald trump behauptet briefwahl seien
nicht weniger als betrug der
kurznachrichtendienst wendet daraufhin
seine regeln an und unterzieht die jump
aussage einem faktencheck samt waren
hinweis der präsident tobt aus
washington berichtet ines trams 100.000
vor ein paar wochen noch hat man diese
zahl als warnung nicht wahrhaben wollen
nun ist sie da in den usa sind über
100.000 menschen an cupid 19 verstorben
das land trauert auch um den 21-jährigen
cody aus colorado
wir verstehen nicht wie ein gesunder 21
jahre alter junge unser junger daran
sterben konnte er hatte dieses große
lachen strahlende blaue augen eine
einmalige persönlichkeit präsident trump
twittert heute sein mitgefühl nachdem
die forderung danach laut geworden war
den familien der 100.000 spricht er
seine herzliche anteilnahme aus auch
seine liebe für alles wofür diese
großartigen menschen standen
doch trump hat noch einen anderen fokus
einen streit mit twitter wegen eines
tritts von ihm indem er briefwahl als
betrügerisch beschreibt twitter
kennzeichnet diese aussage als nicht
korrekt nun droht vom den sozialen
medien mit regulierung oder gar
schließung
dies wird heute ein großer tag warnt er
für die sozialen medien und für fairness
einen erlass will er wohl unterzeichnen
der den rechtlichen schutz von
plattformen wie twitter oder facebook
einschränken könnte
damit wären die dann voll verantwortlich
für alle inhalte
ich denke nicht dass facebook oder
andere internet plattformen zum ski
richter über die wahrheit werden sollten
also entscheiden sollten was wahr und
unwahr ist trump so die demokraten will
mit seinem vorgehen gegen die sozialen
medien schlicht von seinem handling der
korona krise ablenken dort präsent ist
weiß der präsident macht ist albern eine
ablenkung lasst uns unseren job machen
und leben retten
100.000 tote die usa stehen vor großen
aufgaben der präsident aber so scheint
es hat oftmals vor allem seine
wiederwahl im kopf empathie wissen in
washington wie reagieren die amerikaner
auf das verhalten ihres präsidenten also
wissen zunächst mal dass 60 prozent der
amerikaner ein comeback der wirtschaft
frühestens für das nächste jahr 2021
erwarten und dass zweifel wachsen an
donald trump auch in seiner
stammwählerschaft zum beispiel älteren
menschen in florida die werden
sicherlich auch registrieren heute dass
der präsident erst zu 20 anderen themen
bzw 20 schwyz getwittert hat zu ganz
anderen themen als die hunderttausend
tote bevor er dann endlich sein bedauern
über diese zahl ausgedrückt hat die
regierung hat derzeit kein sichtbares
konzept keine strategie gegen die
wirtschaftskrise bestehen ja bei fast 41
millionen arbeitslosen 15 prozent
arbeitslosenrate und seine eigene partei
die republikaner sagen ganz klar es wird
kein weiteres hilfspaket geben weil die
staatsverschuldung schon viel zu hoch
ist und vor dem hintergrund glaube ich
sind das alles auch ein stückweit gründe
dafür dass trump jetzt gegen twitter
vorgehen will
er braucht diesen direkten kanal zu
seinen anhängern um gewissermaßen
unwidersprochen seine sicht der dinge
kundzutun
und da sind dann waren hinweise zu
seinen behauptungen ich würde mal sagen
hinderlich möglicherweise auch
gefährdend für seine wiederwahl
danke für diese einschätzung aus
washington emma thivessen nach china
trotz massiver internationaler kritik
und drohungen aus washington hat der
volkskongress den weg frei gemacht für
das umstrittene sogenannte
sicherheitsgesetz in hongkong
kritiker fürchten dass peking damit
offenbar endgültig die
demokratiebewegung und alle kritischen
stimmen in der ehemaligen britischen
kolonie tilgen will thomas garcia
berichtet aufmarsch auf einer
hauptstraße polizei patroulliert ein
sinnbild für die situation in der
metropole sagen beobachter
hongkong ist ein polizeistaat geworden
die polizisten haben unbegrenzte macht
sie können jeden einfach festnehmen und
festhalten
alle macht geht vom volkskongress aus
chinas staatspräsident lässt den peking
ein sogenanntes sicherheitsgesetz
abnicken ein knopfdruck und polizisten
aber auch richter können bald vorgehen
gegen so heißt es subversive aktivitäten
alles zu betont man stütze das prinzip
ein land zwei systeme
falsch sagen die demonstranten in
hongkong ein land ein system das wolle
die kommunistische regierung in china
und unterbindet kundgebungen allein
gestern gab es 300 festnahmen
was geschieht jetzt mit denen die
protestieren kommt die nächste
generation in umerziehungslager
besorgnis auch international der us
außenminister schreibt auf twitter
hongkong ist nicht mehr unabhängig von
china er meint die sondervorteile der
metropole als finanzstandort sollen weg
das treffe auf china
die antwort aus peking moderat wir
müssen uns gegenseitig respektieren und
eine zusammenarbeit anstreben die allen
nützt ein signal der stärke sendet
peking übrigens auch in sachen corona
man steht eng zusammen sagen die bilder
nicht einmal das virus könne china
bezwingen
corona ärzte und wissenschaftler sammeln
immer mehr erkenntnisse über das virus
so zeigt sich dass es längst nicht nur
die lunge angreift sondern den ganzen
körper schädigen kann auch herz hirn und
mähren aus dem klinikum stuttgart
berichtet zusammen von lojewski gabriele
nägele kann nicht sprechen und erst seit
gestern muss sie nicht mehr zur dialyse
und dennoch ist sie für die ärzte im
klinikum stuttgart eine
erfolgsgeschichte die wenigsten corona
patienten haben einen verlauf wie sie
ihn hatte überlebt leber und
nierenversagen thrombose anhalts
neurologische ausfälle
wir sehen eine unglaubliche explosion an
entzündungswerten das triggert gefäß
ereignisse des trägers gerinnung system
angesehen plötzlich ein organversagen
das ist schon was spannend da möchte man
natürlich wissen warum ist das so
warum ist das so dem sind sie im größten
krankenhaus baden württembergs auf der
spur über 300 ct aufnahmen von
infizierten patienten haben professor
götz martin richter und sein team
ausgewertet das ergebnis die krankheit
kann wenn das immunsystem das virus
nicht rechtzeitig bekämpft den ganzen
körper befallen
das eingehen auf die individuelle
krankheits schwere die ist von
fundamentaler bedeutung auch zum
beispiel zu erkennen weil man
blutgerinnungshemmers medikamente also
im sprachgebrauch allgemein als
blutverdünnung bezeichnet geben muss um
dann vielleicht diese schweren
komplikationen weiter zu reduzieren
denn ein großes problem bei kubi
patienten sind thrombosen bluttropfens
die sich zum beispiel in bayern bilden
sich durch den blutfluss lösen und dann
eine lungenembolie auslösen können
so war es bei affen niveau recker die
embolie kräftigen körper des 46 jährigen
familienvaters zusätzlich an
da wurde schlechter dass ich mich nicht
hinlegen kommt
also ich konnte nicht mal den rücken ich
mal seitlich ich musste also praktisch
nur so stehen davon nachts für die
mediziner ist es eine herausforderung
die symptome der krankheit möglichst
frühzeitig zu deuten um so einen
dramatischen verlauf zu verhindern
ein blick auf die aktuelle entwicklung
zeigt in deutschland sinkt die zahl der
neuinfektionen weiter
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage steckten sich täglich 440 menschen
an
insgesamt registrierte die johns hopkins
universität stand 18 30 fast 182.000
infizierte davon gelten mehr als 100
63.000 als genesen 8463 menschen sind in
verbindung mit cupid 19 gestorben
aber die lage bleibt fragil bei einem
baptisten gottesdienst in frankfurt am
mai hatten main hatten sich viele
menschen mit dem corona virus angesteckt
die zahl ist mittlerweile auf 200
gestiegen 9 sind im krankenhaus davon
einer auf der intensivstation und in
einem verteilzentrum von ps in
langenhagen bei hannover haben sich mehr
als 70 mitarbeiter infiziert auch coop
19 fälle in einer kita und einer schule
in hannover gehen nach angaben der
behörden auf ansteckungen bei bp es
zurück
die korona pandemie war auch
bestimmendes thema im bundestag der hat
zwei konkrete maßnahmen beschlossen
eltern die wegen corona ihre kinder zu
hause betreuen müssen und nicht arbeiten
können bekommen längere lohnfortzahlung
jedes elternteil hat zehn statt bisher
sechs wochen anspruch alleinerziehende
20 wochen und für essen in gaststätten
werden ab juli nur noch sieben statt
bisher 19 prozent mehrwertsteuer fällig
erstmal für ein jahr
das soll restaurants entlasten beide
beschlüsse müssen noch in den bundesrat
die zustimmung dort gilt als sicher
während in deutschland die korona app
noch auf sich warten lässt ist
frankreich schon ein stück weiter das
parlament hat den weg für stop go weg
freigemacht kommende woche kann man die
app aufs handy laden
dann gelten auch die lockerungen die
prämie phillipe vor zwei stunden
verkündete hotels und restaurants dürfen
wieder öffnen
über die app der franzosen berichtet
thomas weide achtung corona risiko sie
kamen in den vergangenen tagen in
kontakt mit jemandem der positiv
getestet wurde
so sieht es aus wenn französinnen und
franzosen gewarnt werden die stop go
wird auf ihr handy laden das parlament
hat dem projekt der regierung nun
zugestimmt franzosen wollen wieder
zurück zu ihrem normalen leben und
wollen dass das geschäftsleben wieder
öffnet diese erbringt ein zusätzliches
sicherheitselement beim wiedergewinnen
der freiheit
wer positiv getestet wurde kann das der
app mitteilen
der name wird dabei nicht übermittelt
stattdessen erkennt die app andere
handys in unmittelbarer nähe auf denen
auch die app ist deren besitzer werden
dann gewarnt
das bringt nichts denn es müssten 50 bis
60 prozent der bevölkerung mitmachen und
das wird nichts auch weil 25 prozent der
franzosen gar kein smartphone abend auch
beim datenschutz sind viele skeptisch
ich will das nicht nutzen weil ich denke
die daten könnten doch für andere dinge
benutzt werden
ich werde mir das nicht runterladen um
nicht verfolgt zu werden
die regierung versucht kritiker zu
beruhigen
topcu beat ist zeitlich begrenzt die
nutzung freiwillig nicht identifizierbar
und transparent es gibt die garantien
dass das privatleben der franzosen
respektiert wird
ursprünglich wollten frankreich und
deutschland gemeinsam eine app
entwickeln doch weil frankreich die
daten zentral speichert wird die
französische äpfel nicht mit der in
deutschland entwickelten kompatibel sein
erinnern sie sich noch an die pkw-maut
das prestige-projekt der csu
ausländische autofahrer sollten sie
zahlen deutsche über die kfz steuer
entlastet werden
aber der europäische gerichtshof sagte
nein
das verstößt gegen eu recht das problem
verkehrsminister scheuer hatte schon
aufträge vergeben für bis zu eine
milliarde euro
ein untersuchungsausschuss soll klären
wer die verantwortung für das
finanzielle desaster trägt heute wurde
horst seehofer befragt der innenminister
war 2013 csu-chef bayerischer
ministerpräsident und einer der väter
der maut pläne
patricia wiedemeier er seit 50 jahren in
der politik und habe seine
wahlversprechen immer gehalten horst
seehofer ist sich keiner schuld bewusst
vor dem untersuchungsausschuss wies er
eine mitschuld an der gescheiterten maut
an einem schaden von mindestens 560
millionen euro zurück ich würde heute
das wieder
machen mit dem aufwendig
parteivorsitzender wäre ich würde heute
nur einen stärkeren klimaschutz als
aspekt darin fahren kann
die pkw-maut sie war das prestige-objekt
der csu im wahlkampf 2013 obwohl der
frühere verkehrsminister ramsauer auch
von der csu gewarnt hatte und zweifel an
der rechtmässigkeit geäußert hatte dass
seehofer peitschte die maut bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen durch die pkw
maut steht im vertrag auch nach der
befragung heute keinerlei
schuldbewusstsein
das kommt immer wieder mal vor dass sein
höchstes gericht politische
entscheidungen korrigiert hätte seehofer
das debakel um die pkw-maut verhindern
können wenn er auf ramsauer gehört hätte
hat er die csu-minister dobrindt und
scheuer zu den verträgen gezwungen viele
offene fragen
wir glauben ihm natürlich überhaupt
nicht dass er da keine weisung oder
anweisung gegeben hat horst seehofer hat
in seinem leben immer anweisungen
gegeben und hat anderen gesagt wie sie
arbeiten sollten was sie zu tun haben
mich hat er nicht überzeugen können es
gibt diese differenz zwischen seehofer
und ramsauer die steht nach wie vor im
raum konnte nicht aufgeklärt werden
der eigentliche auftrag des ausschusses
ist es zu prüfen ob die verträge zur
maut rechtmäßig waren der auftritt von
horst seehofer hilft dabei nicht weiter
fünf jahre nach dem hacker angriff auf
den deutschen bundestag wurde heute der
russische botschafter ins auswärtige amt
geladen
denn für die bundesregierung ist klar
moskau steckt hinter der attacke
es lägen belastbare hinweise vor dass
der hauptverdächtige zum zeitpunkt des
angriffs dem militärischen geheimdienst
russlands angehört hat erklärte das
ministerium
die landwirte geben nicht auf in vielen
deutschen städten waren heute wieder
traktoren konvois unterwegs aus protest
gegen die agrarpolitik wie hier in
hannover forderten die bauern den
rücktritt von bundesumweltministerin
schulze sie kritisieren die geplanten
schärferen vorgaben zum insekten und
umweltschutz und weitere dünne
beschränkungen die schuld etwa für das
artensterben in deutschland dürfen nicht
den landwirten in die schuhe geschoben
werden so die demenz
rampen und jetzt reden wir über cookies
aber nicht über schokokekse sondern über
cookies im internet das sind kleine
dateien die auf der festplatte
gespeichert werden sie sollen das surfen
erleichtern einige cookies erlauben es
den firmen aber auch profile von nutzern
zu erstellen etwa für persönlich
zugeschnittene werbung
jetzt hat der bundesgerichtshof
entschieden damit ein unternehmen
bestimmte cookies setzen darf muss der
nutzer in jedem fall aktiv zustimmen
relaxte man wer welches produkt wann wo
und wie lange anschaut erfährt die werbe
branche durch cookies wenn hierdurch
persönlichkeitsprofile für werbung
angelegt werden verlangt das
datenschutzrecht die einwilligung der
internetnutzer und so blocken beim
surfen ständig fenster auf in denen
nutzer über die verwendung von cookies
entscheiden sollen die meinungen dazu
geteilt finde ich sehr gut dass ich
aktiv gewarnt werde und ich gehe dann
oft aus dem seiten auch wieder raus ich
muss ehrlich sagen ich dachte da nicht
so drauf obwohl ich das wahrscheinlich
mehr tun sollte
ich finde es gut dass mal davor gewarnt
wird wollen wir dann entscheiden kann
ich möchte dass cookies gespeichert
werden oder es schon möchte das nicht
das problem
viele unternehmen haben die auswahl für
cookies schon voreingestellt und so
klicken die user lieber auf alles klar
ok oder einverstanden stadt cookies
mühsam in einstellungen abzuwählen
doch eine solche gestaltung ist
rechtswidrig entschied heute der
bundesgerichtshof auf eine klage der
verbraucherzentrale
es ist keine wirksame einwilligung wenn
hier ein voreingestellte sun kreuz
kästchen
vorgesehen ist dass von dem nutzer dann
abgewählt werden muss das bedeutet die
entscheidung gegen cookies dafür user
nicht komplizierter sein als die
entscheidung für cookies vorbildlich ist
eine gestaltung wenn wie in diesem
beispiel eine wahlfreiheit zwischen zwei
gleich gestalteten auswahlmöglichkeiten
besteht in diesen fällen zeigen studien
dass sich nur zur meisten gegen cookies
entscheiden
das urteil des bgh stärkt somit die
datenhoheit der nutzer und machte es für
die werbe branche in zukunft deutlich
schwieriger
so analysierte werbung anzubieten
cookies im internet was ist das wo sind
sie nützlich und wo können sie schaden
all das können sie nochmal in ruhe
nachlesen in der zdf- heute- app kompakt
zusammengefasst in einer facto box sie
hat mit loriot gearbeitet spielte bei
[ __ ] you goethe mit hat den deutschen
filmpreis bekommen irm hermann war eine
der vielseitigsten und renommiertesten
deutschen schauspielerinnen
nun ist sie mit 77 jahren gestorben
angefangen hatte sie als sekretärin bis
sie mit mitte zwanzig den regisseur
rainer werner fassbinder kennenlernte
rund 20 mal stand sie für ihn vor der
kamera
später arbeitete ihren herrmann mit
regisseuren wie werner herzog und
christoph schlingensief auch im zdf war
sie zu sehen in der krimireihe ein
starkes team
mehr als 30 jahre nach dem mauerfall
bekommt deutschland in berlin ein
freiheits und einheitsdenkmal
ursprünglich sollte es vergangenes jahr
eröffnet werden aber manches dauert eben
länger in der hauptstadt heute endlich
der tag des symbolischen baubeginns für
das denkmal
es soll eine begehbare wippe entstehen
direkt vor dem rekonstruierten
stadtschloss geplante eröffnungstermin
ende kommenden jahres nur ganz
vereinzelte kleine schauer im
bayerischen wald ansonsten überall
sonnig und warum das ist die prognose
von katja horneffer das heute-journal
wie gehabt um viertel vor zehn mit claus
kleber ich danke für ihr interesse und
wünsche ihnen noch einen unbeschwerten
abend bis morgen und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren in den
vergangenen 24 stunden ist eine
kaltfront über uns hinweggezogen
besonders über den osten und über den
süden in sachsen hat es recht kräftig
geregnet und in bayern gab es doch
einige regenschauer und gewitter im
westen haben sie von der kalte und wenig
gemerkt höre ich dass da mal ein paar
wolken durch gezogen sind auch in der
nacht ist es häufig klar und einzig im
bayerischen wald kann es noch mal einen
kleinen regenschauer geben
die temperaturen sinken auf werte
zwischen 10 und 3 grad und klettere
morgen auf ähnliche werte wie heute
nämlich auf 15 bis maximal 24 grad am
wärmsten wird es am niederrhein im osten
wechseln sonne und wolken miteinander ab
und in niederbayern kann das auch noch
mal einen kleinen regenschauer geben
im westen dagegen zwischen sylt und
basel
da strahlt die sonne das hat allerdings
auch zur folge dass die waldbrandgefahr
wirklich hoch ist besonders nicht nur
hier im nordosten sondern auch in teilen
von bayern baden-württemberg hessen
rheinland-pfalz nordrhein-westfalen und
daran ändert sich auch in den nächsten
tagen nur wenig denn das wetter ändert
sich wenig pfingstsonntag kommen einige
regenwolken aus tschechien und
österreich heran und der pfingstmontag
wird dann richtig schwül für einige mit
bis zu 27 grad
schönen abend noch